that seems out of control if you're
starting to conclude the federal
agencies are out of control and have
hollowed out democracy to the point
where it's not recognizable
here's a shocking story new reporting
tonight from John Solomon at the website
just the news reveals that doj began
spying on the U.S Congress in 2017.
specifically doj sought Grand Journey
subpoenas for the personal emails of at
least two staffers on the house Intel
committee including cash Patel now this
is right around the time the house Intel
committee was probing the Russia
collusion hoax
now Devin Nunes you would think would be
Beyond
attack by the agency since he was the
chairman of the house Intel committee at
the time he was the guy overseeing the
Intel agencies
it looks like he wasn't we now know
Devin Nunes joins us tonight Congressman
thank you so much uh for coming on so it
I I should say it looks like you were
spied upon as well
um what do you make of this
now that we know it for sure well look
at this point at this point Tucker it
appears to be that it's not just a
couple staff it looks like it probably
is more we only have a couple subpoenas
at this point so we're this is probably
just the tip of the iceberg and and what
this is is by remember they targeted my
lawyers
so and if you go back to the time frame
what was happening we were in a brawl
with the Department of Justice and the
FBI because we caught them
spying on the Trump campaign and other
Republican operatives in 2016 that
continued on to 2017. at this time we
had confronted high-level Folks at the
highest level of the Department of
Justice and the FBI saying that look we
think you guys might have a problem here
too maybe you should recuse yourself
maybe you shouldn't be involved you
would have thought they would have got
to the bottom of it but instead what
they did is they did this cute little
way of reverse targeting me
by going after my staff to figure out
how did we know this information what
were we going to do with this
information and this was all just months
before we made this all public that the
FBI used the Clinton and DNC dirt to spy
on Trump in the Trump campaign
you can't have a democracy in which
unelected bureaucrats with guns control
elected officials that is not a
democracy why does no one burn this down
and start again it's it's the most
serious possible threat it's a much
greater threat than any foreign
government why does no one ever do
anything about this
well look we tried Tucker and you know
we made 14 criminal referrals I assume
John Durham has that now look a lot of
these referrals did involve lying and
misleading Congress obstruction of
justice these are all things if I'm John
Durham I know that they're trying to
close him down the bite Administration
has closed him down but I think Congress
my former colleague should be pushing
this information asked Durham to look at
this because this is clearly in the
realm of what John Durham's scope was to
look at and I know he brought some cases
in D.C against against citizens uh he
has yet to bring any charges against the
very people who we trust with these with
these really high level powers that
appear to well not appear they did I
mean they turned it against the United
States Congress to try to figure out
either to try to figure out what we're
doing or try to get blackmail on us
you and it's very clear that members of
Congress are being blackmailed I can say
that maybe you can't but it's true as
you know Devin you know I appreciate it
coming on tonight thank you for bringing
us to our attention always a pleasure
thank you